they died out obviously yeah Jay nice
what's the biggest perk of going inside
these parties biggest perk I seen seen
some of that seems to people that are
fans that I guess yeah well yeah Robert
came right here we haven't seen it do
you tell the UTS family anymore anyway I
mean big thing is you're always part of
him yeah like I was gonna phone the
producer like last night you know or
hate we're her friends so yeah like to
do something that's come and seize it
no no no friends for friends but I'm
sure you go visit her and always yeah
your tours coming up very soon how are
you guys planning to make this work
long-distance leave you on the road
within no it's ending right once war
starts we're done that's that's the deal
no I mean I'll be made the season for
Dancing with the Stars so yeah so I mean
we've done it before we've done it how
many tours apart five tours and say no
thanks we got it I know that this tour
is like a very it's a solo tour but I
would love to see you and Julian back in
action again but like a televised
special have you guys ever talked about
that we we have actually yeah absolutely
I mean
never said never I think that's
something that might be in the star in
the future and then we'll see what
happens we'll see but I think we could I
think we could do that yeah acting I
member aged in Nashville for a couple
years and you are phenomenal on it more
scripted television in the future I
think there's the right thing that comes
around the right timing and if there's
schedule allows I'm great but for me
like I love doing live things with the
live theatre live audience logos for me
really like fuel means I'm very
passionate about stuff if I'm doing
projects like that I tend to sort of
stay with those but if something comes
around I'm like oh my god this is like
amazing then of course of course
yeah we've been dating a while what is
the secret what do you love most about
each other honestly we've kind of
figured out communication is key balance
and balancing each other out we're
pretty much opposite I would say we're
very opposite actually
but I will say that she's definitely
learned that a vacation with me is not a
vacation it's an adventure when I gave
everyone of a Katia's like yeah we're
not sleeping we're going out in
helicopters we're jumping out of things
we're going we're going swimming with
sharks and dolphins yeah you would think
that it would be like actually going and
just laying out by the pool or like on
the beach but absolutely not I sleep
when he had its videos what about a show
for you guys in the future would you
ever do it tour together like a
headlining like the two of you really
[Music]